bonjour odile dumeaux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france elle va parler de ce nouveau
traitement qui est nantais en quoi
consiste-t-il exactement
alors c'est un traitement que nous
développons depuis donc bientôt deux ans
qui est un anticorps dits polyclonale
donc c'est un anticorps qui a la
particularité de reconnaître le virus
quelles que soient les variants et donc
nous avons depuis deux ans maintenant
étudier précisément le travail de ce
traitement et le faire les mécanismes
d'action ce traitement et nous avons pu
démontrer qu'il était en mesure de
bloquer le virus en le neutralisant et
en ayant un effet anti-inflammatoire
c'est un des mécanismes d'action ce
médicament donc on deux ans j'imagine
qu'il ya suffisamment de recul pour dire
que ça marche
alors il faut bien être précis dans ce
qu'on dit quand on dit ah ça marche il
ya plusieurs niveaux de ça marche il ya
un niveau qui est ce qu'on appelle le
niveau in vitro ou là on regarde dans le
laboratoire comment ça comment ça
fonctionne donc là effectivement ce que
nous avons pu démontrer chez xénon terra
c'est que notre anticorps qui s'appelle
le xav 19 et bien effectivement il
marche il marche sur le virus initial
mais il marche aussi sur les différents
variant est ce que nous avons annoncé il
ya deux jours c'est qu'il marche sur le
variant au micro et en cela il est très
intéressant puisque tous les autres
anticorps actuellement utilisés contre
le virus ont malheureusement perdu leur
efficacité contre 7 variant au micro
alors ça alors au deuxième niveau de sa
marche qui est le niveau ça marche
invivo c'était sur l'animal donc ça
aussi c'est fait il ya un troisième
niveau de sa marge qui est le niveau où
on fait des essais cliniques chez les
patients donc ce niveau il est en cours
d'analysé
mais effectivement les premiers
résultats montrent que le traitement
gamme 19 ne présente pas de risque pour
les patients et qu'il a une présomption
d'efficacité ce qu'on appelle une
présomption d'efficacité qui le rend
particulièrement intéressant c'est un
traitement qui devrait être pris quand
les symptômes se font plus pesant c'est
à dire quand il y à un risque d'aller à
l'hôpital quand est ce qu'il faudrait
prendre ce type de traitement
alors nous ce que nous considérons c'est
que le traitement âmes 19 il est adapté
une fois que les gens les patients ont
passé un certain niveau d'aggravation
alors est ce que vous savez que quand on
contracte la maladie on peut d'abord on
un cube ensuite on est malade pendant
cinq jours c'est ça un jour sont en
général relativement bénins et aussi
ciel entre le sixième et neuvième jour
une partie des patients dieu merci pas
trop nombreuses peut s'aggraver alors
que les autres vont récupérer et c'est à
cette période entre le sixième et
neuvième jour qu'il est intéressant de
recevoir notre anticorps alors on sait
que le gouvernement français a acheté
aussi des des traitements extrêmement
cher d'ailleurs ça veut dire que ceux là
sont caduques
alors malheureusement ça c'est une
boutique publication de la semaine
dernière les traitement par anticorps
monoclonaux qui sont bien différents du
nôtre puisque notre anti corps et
polyclonale les traitement par anticorps
monoclonaux donc ce s'avère aujourd'hui
inefficace sur le variant au micro ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on pourra pas les
utiliser pour des passions qui aurait
d'autres variantes mais en tout cas pour
ce variant n'a malheureusement ils sont
désormais inutilisable alors vous fait
office de précurseur j'imagine avec ce
traitement est ce que ça va prendre du
temps pour l'homologuer
alors précurseur oui alors il faut en
même temps bien avoir en tête que nous
ne sommes pas tout seul il ya
aujourd'hui une dizaine de projets
d'anticorps polyclonaux au monde en
développement mais nous sommes
effectivement le l'un des plus en avance
avec un projet argentin et combien de
temps faut-il pour l'homologuer écouter
ça ne dépend pas de nous nous avons
déposé un dossier auprès des autorités
réglementaires françaises qui ont une
une indépendance qui est absolument
nécessaire est vraiment j'y tiens et
cela souligne comme étant qualité des
autorités réglementaires françaises qui
est leur indépendance et les autorités
tang aujourd'hui des données cliniques
et données cliniques nous espérons les
recevoir dans les prochains jours alors
est-ce qu'on peut évaluer déjà le coût
d'un tel traitement ou est ce que c'est
encore trop tôt
alors c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt
parce que nous sommes dans une phase où
on est une toute petite entreprise
française basée à nantes et nous sommes
dans la phase d'industrialisation ont
fait progressivement monter l'échelle de
production du médicament malgré tout
je pense que vous avez en tête que le
président de la république a commandé
ces taxes est noté dès le printemps de
réserver un certain nombre de doses pour
les patients français lorsque nos
traitements seraient donc comme vous
dites homologué et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui 25 mille doses prêtes pour
les patients français qui pourraient en
avoir besoin et qu'ils seraient
distribués dans les hôpitaux ou en
médecine de ville alors il serait a
priori ce que nous a demandé santé
publique france et le ministère de la
santé en fait inquiets ministère qui a
commandé ces doses nous a demandé de les
mettre à disposition dans l'ensemble des
hôpitaux français pour les patients qui
correspondent bien évidemment aux
critères
précis d'indication de ce médicament
c'est à dire principalement comme je
vous l'expliquais à une période du
développement de la maladie entre 6 et 9
jours merci beaucoup aux d'il divo pour
toutes ces précisions et qui donne de
l'espoir avec ses nouveaux traitements
qui serait donc efficaces contre le
nouveau variant omicron merci